my name is dan hello I'm gonna talk to
you all about a problem that I
encountered recently that has caused me
a great amount of anxiety so this gap
between a program and it's proof shall
serve as the simulacrum for that anxiety
through the duration of this talk before
I get into the weeds of what I mean when
I talk about this gap I'd like to talk
about a little bit about how I came to
know about this problem now I work on
autonomous vehicles what we're looking
at here is a vehicle which we can assume
has some level of autonomy given the
plethora of sensor systems that are on
it we see cameras and radars and light
ARS in the front and in the back but
there's also a smattering of acronyms
here this aesol ABCD now aesol stands
for automotive safety integrity level
and it kind of prescribes a spectrum of
rigor that we should apply to some
component in a vehicle architecture
which corresponds to how safety critical
that is in the overall architecture so
you can imagine something like the
window motor if the window motor fails
it doesn't really go beyond just being
kind of annoying particularly on a very
cold day the failure of the window motor
is not going to be catastrophic for the
vehicle or for the persons in the
vehicle on the other hand something like
the power steering system or the braking
system now if there is a failure in that
type of system it's going to be
catastrophic for the safety of the car
and for the people in the car so this is
something that we apply the highest
level of rigor to and this is something
that we would say was a severe ated
where the lowest amount of rigor is a
Salette now when we're talking about the
software architecture for an autonomous
vehicle it tends to look like this is
kind of a reductive logical architecture
for an autonomous vehicle where we have
some set of sensors that are pulling
data in from the outside world and
that's getting fed into some AI or ml
that is doing computations it's making
inferences and it's ultimately turning
those inferences into some decisions and
those decisions are doled out to some
other subsystems that are responsible
for actuated in the vehicle now I
personally don't work on this AI box
here which is where you usually think or
what you usually think of when you're
thinking about the tech in autonomous
vehicles it's where all of it is focused
I work on the infrastructure in the cars
which would be like these arrows that
are coming into the AI coming out of the
AI as well as these systems that are
responsible for turning those decisions
into commands for the subsystems of the
vehicle like the steering the throttle
of the braking and I believe I kind of
fundamentally believe that this
infrastructure in the in the vehicle
ought to be rated at an acyl D level and
I can kind of give you an example of why
the data that is coming in from those
sensors before it is useful to the AI it
has to be translated it has to be sort
of in an information theoretical way
into something that the AI can
understand and perform computations on
and simultaneously oftentimes this data
from these sensors is also being fused
together from all of the disparate
sensors into some format that's easier
for the AI to then perform computations
on we call this sensor fusion and in
this process of fusion in translation we
want to have the most possible certainty
that we're not compromising the
integrity or the fidelity of that data
before it reaches the AI because if we
did it would cause the AI to fail to be
able to make proper inferences we've
actually seen examples where a single
pixel can cause a computer vision
algorithm to cease to be able to
recognize simple objects now on the
other side of the AI coming out of the
AI into these actuators we want to have
with high certainty that the messages
are being received in the communication
protocol and also that when those
commands are received by the systems
that are responsible for actuation that
they do exactly that
nothing more and nothing less and so
when we have a component in a vehicle
that is acyl de-rated we are required to
apply some formal methods to it some
kind of mathematical reasoning or maybe
it's model checking or something like
that and it is through this that I came
to know this problem this gap between a
program and its proof now there are some
sort of traditional approaches to this
problem and we'll take a look at those
first the first option is just is just
me I as an observer human being I say
this program and this proof totally the
same thing
written a program in one language I've
written a proof mathematically or in
some proof assistant and I give them
both thumbs up and you have to trust me
so you can imagine writing some grand
beautiful and elegant proof and it shows
that all of the properties about the
program that you care about hold and
it's wonderful and then you write your
program and the extent of it is
something like this obviously this is a
ridiculous and hyperbolic example but
the point that I'm trying to make here
is that there's nothing mechanical that
tethers the proof to its program in
vice-versa so another approach to this
is to extract a proof or extract a
program from the proof assistant in
which we've reasoned about that program
now the proof assistants that are
popular in specifically my domain in
automotive are these is mostly [ __ ] a
little bit of Isabel and higher-order
logic family or Agda a little bit of
Agda
but the languages that we can extract
from in those proof assistants tend to
be these functional languages like
Haskell Oh camel our scheme Isabel can
do some ML and some Scala for some crazy
reason but unfortunately none of those
languages are an option for me in this
architecture and that is because
especially in we're talking about the
actuation down here there are small
systems that may have a real time
constraint or perhaps it's just an
embedded system maybe it runs on a
microkernel that doesn't have a full
POSIX environment so a language that is
lazily evaluated or has
non-deterministic memory management it's
just not an option for me so typically
when we are met with these constraints
we choose the language where we can
manage the memory deterministically
where we're responsible for the memory
management we use something like C or
C++ now if we could extract a C for
program from a proof than that that
would be a solution to this problem and
there is actually active work to pull a
C program from a [ __ ] proof and here is
a small example of some code that has
been extracted from a [ __ ] proof if we
look at line about 106 you see that
we're doing a math operation to index
to a buffer bitwise oaring casting and
shifting left all in one line no
subjectively this code is terrifying to
me I would never want this to be in some
car that I expect to keep me safe in
anyway but objectively given the
constraints that I have in these systems
I would have to teach the extractor for
each individual sort of ad-hoc platform
that I have to deploy these systems on
to so I would be rethinking the
extractor for each process and it just
becomes an untenable problem and
secondarily the standards body that
gives us the aesol sort of ratings say
that if you have code that is generated
or extracted don't look at it it's fine
whatever came out of some other tool
don't even review it so you are wholly
trusting in the extraction process and
in most cases this extraction process
isn't even verified by the proof
assistant from which it is extracting a
program so we're once again left here
with this problem where we have one
system that is wholly observational and
has no sort of mechanical way of
tethering a proof to a program we have
another one that is totally mechanical
and is very difficult to reason about as
a programmer because I am a programmer
I'm not a mathematician I want to write
a program and then be able to reason
about that mathematically after the fact
so what if there was another option that
we had some way that we could kind of
think about what it means to run a
program and how we can make that overlap
with a proof about that program but
before I get into those details I'd like
to take a slight digression about this
sort of bifurcation that we're presented
with when we are talking about formally
reasoning about a program or a
programming language we are presented
with this idea of syntax and these are
the syntactical objects that we're
actually actively working with when
we're writing our programs this is the
things like structs and you know 8-bit
integers and it also is how scope is
managed and things like curly braces and
semicolons and all of this and it
describes our programs syntactically but
on the semantic side we're more talking
about what it means to run that program
what is its model when we give it some
output
what is the or we give it some input
what is the output of that program now
there's several approaches to reason
about a program semantically and the one
that we'll focus on for this talk is
something that is called denotational
semantics and it's raison d'etre is to
glue the syntax of a program to some
meaning in some other more universal
language here is a couple of examples we
have some 8-bit integer an unsigned
integer which we would think about in
through our sort of semantic function
that map's it to some meaning as the set
of the natural numbers such that they
are all less than or equal to the number
255 we have the same example here for an
unsigned integer of 16-bit width and it
has the same kind of rules applied to it
so the takeaway here is that we are
mapping our syntactical objects to the
universal language of mathematics and so
through this denotational semantics we
can start reasoning about our program in
a mathematical way so given that we'd
like to talk a little bit about type
theory type theory is a foundational and
constructive way of reasoning about
mathematical objects you typically see
it written in this way we have some term
in some type there's a concrete example
you have you would read this as saying
that true is of type bool the thing on
the left is called a term it's the value
and the thing on the right is the type
now it's type theory is also
computational in the same way that a
program is inherently computational we
are walking through a program in
computing the commands line by line type
theory can also capture this notion of
computation what we're looking at here
is called an inference rule for a type
theory and the way that we read it is we
say if the statement above on this on
the top of the line is true then we can
infer the statement on the bottom line
the characters that we see on the far
left here we have first a gamma and then
a thing called the turn style the gamma
is what is supposed to be our context
it's the things that we know thus far as
we're doing these inferences or it could
also be the other rules that we have
like this to tell us how to make
inferences about other types
and then the turnstile denotes assertion
so what we're to read this rule out loud
we would say that given our context we
know that a the term a has type a and
the term F is a function that map's A's
to B's and when we apply F to a we can
infer that we will get something of type
B so if we can model computation in type
theory can we capture the semantics of
our program entirely through this
framework and it turns out that no not
quite
type theory a simple type theory in and
of itself is not sufficient for actually
reasoning entirely about our program
it's just not a rich enough system so
there is another option this notion of
dependent type theory is the idea that
you have some type that is dependent on
a value or a term from another type so
what we're looking at here is called a
PI type and we were to read it it would
say that for us to produce a B I first
need a value of type a if we use our
bool example before we would say that to
produce a B with true would be a
completely disjoint type from producing
a B with the term false so this means
that B is a family of types but to
actually produce one of those families I
first need to have a value of the type
on which it depends now in the same way
that a type theory is computational so
is dependent type theory we can apply
this same application role here except
for in this case when we apply our F to
our a we produce a B that is indexed
that's what this is called when we put
our term inside the B to produce a
family to index a B to get a B of a so
what does this mean it's a rich enough
it's a richer system and we're trying to
find a way to reason completely about
our program in some mathematical
language and if so the question is can
we
is it a rich enough system does it
provide all the tools that we need and
it turns out that it actually yes it
does this is a quote from a paper called
wine dependent types matter and what it
ultimately says is that we can specify
an entire program the
complete specification of the program's
behavior we can capture that in the
dependent type theory and so what we
have arrived at now is effectively a
very meandering recapitulation of
something that is called the Curie
Howard correspondence the Curie Howard
correspondence simply states that
between two formal systems there exists
some correspondence so this mathematical
correspondence to the way that we think
about our program is an instance of the
curry Howard correspondence there is the
same correspondence between type theory
and category theory or logic and type
theory all of this are related in some
way and so what does this mean for the
problem at hand well it really just
means that we have a technical term for
this thing that has caused me such
stress over the last few months but
given that we know that we can reason
entirely about our program from a
dependent type theory but does it help
us beyond just giving us a technical
word for what this gap is called and it
turns out that yes because we can
specify the entire sort of behavior of
our program in the types that we can in
fact make assertions about the
correctness of that code and this is
because in a dependent type theory the
terms and the types this gap between
them is blurred they both exist on sort
of the same namespace so to speak and so
we can reduce all of the reasoning that
we want to make about a program to type
checking a sufficiently sophisticated
dependent type checker can actually
verify and we would produce a program
which is correct by construction so
given that why don't we just write our
program in a language that is actually
executable that has dependent types this
this doesn't just bridge the gap it
erases it all together because the
program and the proof exists in the same
sort of formal system but for the same
reasons as before we can't run either of
those languages here lazily evaluated
non-deterministic memory management etc
etc so
enter rest rest provides us in its type
system a sort of foundational or
primitive subset that we can use to
start to wedge dependent type behavior
into our programs and I can give you
some examples what we're looking at here
is a type level definition of the
natural numbers on the right we have the
dependent type semantics of that natural
number definition and on the Left we
have the rest code so we will begin by
defining the natural numbers as a type
and then we have two constructors we
have a constructor 0 which represents
the number 0 and then we have a
successor function and to produce the
natural numbers we just reapply the
successor function over and over again
this is called the inductive definition
of the naturals you may also see it as
the piano numbers now on the left we can
produce reproduce this sort of semantics
in rusts type system by gluing together
two structs with a traits and that trait
is that sort of higher-order thing that
lets us treat types like terms so we can
begin to induce our natural numbers at
the type level now from there we can
build up in this example here that we're
looking at is a vector whose type is
dependent on its size this is when
someone says am i doing dependent types
this is the example that we always see
it's kind of the canonical introductory
level example what we see on the right
is our vector which is parameterized
this is a non dependent type by some
type X which is to say that all of the
elements in this vector will have type X
but it's indexed and that index is how
we introduce our dependency by a natural
number and then we have two constructors
the same as before
one that produces us an empty vector
which has type size zero and in the cons
constructor which is a dependent
function that is dependent on that in
the little end and it sticks things into
the vector by taking some X and an
existing vector and stuffing it in and
then returning a new vector whose size
has been increased by one which we get
by applying the successor function once
we have the same sort of semantic
objects on the left side in rust code
where we have our natural number two
then we have a vector that's holding a
rest vector inside but it's also indexed
by some natural number and when we do
operations on this thing where we call
the cons function it actually produces a
new vector who has a new type that is
dependent on its size so our third and
this example is the most salient for us
in particular because these programs
that were writing here these very small
ad hoc programs can tend to be fully
represented kind of all the way down to
borrow a turn of phrase in state
machines and not just the individual
programs themselves but also the
communication protocols between the AI
and the systems that are responsible for
actuation and we can represent a state
machine in rust type system in the same
way that we can give a demand
dependently typed semantics for a state
machine and this one is a little bit
more complicated we begin by creating
states that is a sum type which means
its it can be either an open type open s
or a closed S and then we have a type
family which is this adj that stands for
adjacency in this case and the types
that are members of this adjacency type
family are the adjacencies to each of
our states and so we see on the
left-hand side the same objects being
kind of recapitulated in rust where when
we apply our transition function rust
compiler can actually help us certify
that we haven't contravened the edges in
this state machine and we have what you
could say is a correct by construction
implementation of the state machine so
it does appear that we can map our
dependent type theory or the semantics
of our programs into a dependent type
theory from rust but as I said before
rust doesn't actually have dependent
types we're kind of wedging them in
through an abuse of the tools that it
provides us and this is not a thing that
we can certify we don't trust rust
compiler to produce correct dependent
types so instead of using denotational
semantics to map our rust program into
some thing in our head because we know
that that's how dependent types work or
on paper somewhere and in a latex
document we should instead use one of
those
that we were looking at before that we
can actually use a sophisticated type
checker to verify the semantics that
we've extracted from the program so we
can use this denotational semantics idea
that we've used to think about our
programs mathematically to map the
semantics of our arrest program into
some Agda program that can be type
checked and certified by the Agnes
compiler who we do actually trust
because it does actually have dependent
types and this begins to a swage my
anxiety I feel a little bit better when
I get to this point but at this point I
have kind of left it at it being purely
observational the dependent type sort of
semantics are all in my head thus far
I've said this is what it looks like I
don't really I have maybe some rigor
applied to that semantic function that
maps from one domain to the other but
it's not mechanized I'd like to be able
to include this in like a CI CD pipeline
or something before my program makes it
anywhere so the next step and this is
the step that really helps me feel a
little bit better kind of level off that
anxiety into more homeostasis level my
normal level of anxiety is the idea of
being able to mechanize that semantic
function in extract the semantics from
our rust code and it's at this point we
have built a bridge I believe from the
program to its proof and this is still
the work that this is we're actively
working on this it's not a totally
solved problem but what we are doing is
trying to figure out what those objects
are what is it how can we fundamentally
represent and then use those as building
blocks as we build up the denotational
semantics of our program and
simultaneously I continue to feel better
the further we get so yeah I think
that's it I'm finished thank you guys
[Applause]
I'm looking at the questions if there
are any now I don't see any in union
grande de no questions does anybody have
any questions it was a couple of things
we would have to teach the extractor
individually like our constraints for
the system like if it has real time
constraints or it runs on a microkernel
it doesn't have a full POSIX environment
but the second problem actually and the
code sample that I pulled that from is
using a like development implementation
of something called Lib GC because in
Cocke it is I think if not impossible
very difficult to manage memory and so
at the top of that file that I showed it
actually says you can run it this way
and link against Lib GC and it'll manage
the memory otherwise it just leaks
memory and it will just eat all the
memory on the system so that is the
problem right now is the idea of
thinking about freeing and malloc Inge
in Cocke is not really a thing or any
other proof assistance is not something
that someone has fully taken on yet yes
in the back there the proof is in Agda
we're the through the dependent types we
believe that we can specify enough of
the program that if it builds then we
can trust it now agda does have the
notion of proofs and somebody's working
on a tactic system as well and this is
the thing that we could if we wanted to
take a step further and like go through
the process of proving things
foundationally in Agda we could once we
have the sort of specification of the
program in its domain yes back there
that is a really good question and I've
forgot to say that this process we can
dog food into the same tool if we write
the tool in rust we can have it verify
the process as well yeah yes totally
so one of the ways that we that is used
to model the semantics of a program is
something called operational semantics
and it is totally focused on input and
output so there's the like example that
you see often times is that if you were
to think about a program operationally
if you had two programs that you were
trying to prove we're operationally
equivalent that read in a string and
capitalize the string and spit it out if
one program did exactly that and another
program did that but then also deleted
your file system those two programs
would be operationally equivalent and so
operational semantics can't capture the
side effects but denotational semantics
can because we're reasoning totally
about all of the objects that were using
yes oh thank you : I think because my
predilection is in type theory and kind
of functional programming and all that
type of thing and so it was my natural
way to kind of approach the problem and
so when I started the first thing that
we did to find out that this was even
sound was the state machines and I had
written it in Haskell first like type
level state machines in Haskell and I
just translated it to rest and so
instead of taking a different approach
it was just because that's where I was
standing at the moment that the idea
kind of came to us yeah yeah
oh yes definitely writing these programs
with this ridiculous type constraint is
really hard
it's very really not very much fun at
all there is some kind of like applying
some of the ways that we can generalize
things in a language like Haskell has
made it a little bit easier like the
state machines thing we can stick into a
monad and then like transition through
them that way so you're not responsible
for rewriting all of the functions but
other than that there isn't yet a
solution to that problem russ has a nice
macro system that helps a little bit but
yeah it's just really syntactically
heavy you're writing huge like type
bounds for each function yeah I think it
was that's actually a really good
question I think because I am NOT a
mathematician I'm a programmer and I
like to be able to write a program first
and then try and derive a mathematical
meaning from it as opposed to reason
about a thing mathematically first and
then come into the program because it's
more natural for me to write a program
than it is approved yeah
yeah that is actually not dissimilar
from his question before no no it's fine
it's fine it's just that the rust code
becomes very long because we're building
up these kind of tight bounds as the
program progresses Oh at runtime no in
rust in particular it and for us
especially since we're not using these
pieces of rust it MA no more fights is
everything so all of that abstraction is
erased at runtime yeah back there
interesting that I I'm not familiar with
ATS the I think the situation there was
would be having to teach the 80s
compiler about the constraints that our
systems have like that they don't have a
POSIX environment or it's running it has
a real time constraint or something like
that which may be trivial I don't know
I'm not familiar with it but I think the
reason why we don't do the extraction
process seems kind of related to that
but maybe I'm wrong yeah yeah
yeah totally we have tried that as well
and easily the longest professional
argument of my life was trying to say
that this is the thing that will work
the state machines one in particular
you're kind of beholding to the program
counter because the types are being
carried all the way through at compile
time and the way that most people want
to write a state machine is through a
dispatch function and a bunch of
handlers and that is not an easy thing
to do in this particular kind of
representation so that is one of the
cases where we found to be hard kind of
like question last yes sir
for me personally because it was
syntactically comfortable I think I had
already played with a little bit coming
out of my interests in type theory and
Haskell I mean I think it would be nice
Idris would be equally as applicable it
was just kind of my preference yeah the
creation of the adjacency list each
inhabitant of a fully applied adjacency
list is a type which is a valid
transition for the type that's indexing
that adjacency list so instead of doing
a type level ad we have to actually
produce a new type from the family of
adjacency lists to get our adjacent
types in the state machine yeah
yes yeah absolutely
so the standards body that gives us a
celerity gives us you has to go through
a certification process process and it
has a big like development process that
has to be certified as well not just the
code in lots of cases they don't want to
look at a terminal they want to see
everything kind of represented in a
formal way and that is a thing that we
have talked about and we'll have to use
a certifier who is comfortable with our
kind of weird predilections yeah yeah we
are just rather than pulling the entire
program we want to pull the
specification which to try and map the
types that we're trying to kind of imbue
with the dependent semantics into types
in Agda that that represent the
semantics so it really is just in so far
as the types and not the like actual
execution of the program at least at
this point yeah totally yeah yeah it is
not no not right now yeah I don't know
who will be it's not my decision
I guess it's related I think yeah I
think the church numerals are the idea
that you can use a function to produce
numbers in the same way that the I think
it may be a more general way of looking
at that inductive definition of the
naturals yeah no problem yeah
no not yet
no I think part of it is that we have
more handheld rusts compiler than we
have AG dos if that makes sense trying
to produce an executable program first
and then figuring out how we can map
that into the domain of Agda so that is
the hard part is translating it more so
than I don't know if that helps at all
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we it's not a thing
that I have encountered no and we're not
running the Agda program we're just type
checking it at this point so it has been
that's not a the not a thing that I've
seen it's really interesting I totally
make sense but that would explain why
all of the languages are extracted into
that Kok extraction to a bunch of lazy
languages anything else we have five
minutes yeah still trying to figure that
out but right now we build the rust
program first and then the extraction
program looks at the syntax of the Russ
program and tries to stick it in Agda
and we can like catch a compile failure
but it is not a thing that is fully
automated that we're like producing
objects continuously yet because we're
still trying to figure how to use it to
be honest
anything else cool I guess I'm done
thank
[Applause]